six two I mean ideally yeah okay okay  okay okay so that that's I want to feel  small no that's I'm not I'm not that's  okay I'm tall too I want a tall man yeah  we don't yeah okay do you want to be  attracted to him I would hope so okay so  so let's take ten percent of men make  more than you yeah yeah now half of them  are below five eight so that's that's  five percent of men okay now now you're  at five percent now you want to be  attracted to him let's say half of them  are ugly that's two percent of guys  and and you have to compete and you  might have to share  because because think about it if you if  you find them attractive and he has all  the things you want that means other  women want him that means every girl in  this room probably wants him that  doesn't mean you have to share it means  you might